so why don't you lift up that face mask
and give me a kiss
did you know mcu's cast members have
played lovers in a bunch of other movies
with a sprawling cast that seems to get
bigger every day
it's no surprise when actors end up
working on other projects
like that time aunt may and tony stark
fell in love in only you
or cap and black widow became an item in
the nanny diaries
it's like watching alternate universe
fan fiction
yeah i missed your laugh
i missed you just one year before they
made their mcu debut
the maximav twins played husband and
wife in 2014's
godzilla aaron taylor johnson and
elizabeth olson played
ford and l brody and even had a kid you
might think transitioning from lovers to
siblings would be awkward but according
to olson it actually helped them prepare
for their roles in age of ultron
we felt like brother and sister making
godzilla so
when you get to work with each other
again you've already established that
familiarity
and then you don't have to do those
beginning steps again baby it's a
beautiful morning you look
beautiful we're doing really sweet i
have another drink hank
this biopic about country western singer
hank williams made an unlikely pair of
loki
and scarlet witch tom hiddleston and
elizabeth olson played hank and audrey
williams in the true story of a man who
was torn apart by his own fame
it's hardly a happy love story the
relationship between the two crumbling
as hank's personal life deteriorates
their characters haven't met in the mcu
but there is a connection between the
two
wanda was exposed to loki's scepter
during hydra's experiments with the mine
stone
however with loki's upcoming disney plus
show and the introduction of the
multiverse
anything's possible if the two ever meet
there's sure to be some conflict
but they do have at least one thing in
common neither of them
are fans of thanos
i'm so sorry he's not funny i don't mean
to be laughing
chris evans and scarlett johansson go
way back
before the mcu even began they first met
while working together on the perfect
score in 2004
and that familiarity served them well in
the nanny diaries three years later
the two had great chemistry as harvard
hottie hayden
and annie the nanny and remained close
friends in real life
in fact when evans was apprehensive
about accepting the role of captain
america
it was scarjo who convinced him he
should go for it who better to seek
advice from than an old friend who was
already part of the mcu
will you marry me still hungry babe i
don't know why
our next unlikely pair comes from 2015's
creed
a spin-off of the rocky movies that
follows the story of apollo creed's son
adonis
who travels to philadelphia to train
with rocky balboa himself
following in his father's footsteps
played by michael b jordan
adonis sparks a romance with bianca
played by tessa thompson
that's right killmonger and valkyrie
these two never shared the screen in the
mcu
but the introduction of the multiverse
really does open infinite possibilities
hey they already replaced gamora with an
alternate timeline version of herself
and end game
why not eric stevens with asgard's
refugees now living on earth
the two could end up bumping elbows
given the right circumstances
okay i gotta fix this
before guardians of the galaxy bradley
cooper and zoe saldana were a couple in
the 2012 drama the words
they even dated after meeting on set in
2011 but broke it off after a few months
in the movie cooper plays a novelist
named rory while saldana plays his
girlfriend and eventual wife dora
in the story of a struggling writer who
finds great success publishing a
manuscript he found and claimed as his
own work
it's very different from the close-knit
yet dysfunctional familial bond the two
share in the galaxy's greatest band of
misfits as rocket raccoon
and gamora i'm not exactly married am i
we're family aren't we zoe saldana was
also married to mark ruffalo in 2014's
infinitely polar bear a film about a
bipolar father
struggling to raise two girls and
rekindle a relationship with his wife
following a mental breakdown all while
the mother is working to earn a good
living to provide for the family
hulk and gamora have never met in the
mcu but we think they would get along
they're both mean and green after all
funny that they never crossed paths
even with hulk somehow ending up on the
distant planet of sakaar
but space is pretty big there are a lot
of other planets in the universe
bradley cooper also shared an on-screen
romance with scarlett johansson in he's
just not that into you
there were even some rumors that they
were dating in real life but if there
was anything between them
it was short-lived in the movie cooper
plays a married man having an affair
with a yoga instructor played by skarjo
until she becomes tired of being the
other woman and breaks things off
in the mcu rocket and black widow began
working together with the other remnants
of the avengers
between the events of infinity war and
endgame we wish we could have seen what
that first meeting was like
i love you
before she became the love of iron man's
life gwyneth paltrow was in an on-screen
romance with mark ruffalo
in 2003's view from the top when the
small town girl donna finally gets her
dream assignment as a flight attendant
it puts a damper on the relationship she
developed along the way
now she's faced with a tough choice in
her pursuit of happiness the man she
loves
or the career she felt she was destined
for the craziest part is this wasn't the
only time pepper potts and bruce banner
were a couple
i'm adam i'm phoebe hi phoebe
paltrow and ruffalo starred as lovers a
second time
in the 2012 film thanks for sharing this
time
ruffalo plays a recovering sex addict
who's trying to date for the first time
since he began his five-year long road
to recovery
while he thinks paltrow's character
phoebe is perfect for him
he's hesitant to tell her the truth
about his history
pepper and bruce are close in the mcu
given bruce's friendship with tony stark
but not that close
bruce and tony are best pros with tony
even trusting him enough to open up
about everything that happened in iron
man 3.
is it me is he picky lupita nyong'o and
winston duke
played a married couple and their
mysterious doppelgangers in 2019's
us writer director jordan peele's
follow-up to his smash hit get out
in the mcu however nyong'o and duke
played nakia
and mbaku hailing from wakanda and
heavily involved in the plot of black
panther
nakia was t'challa's love interest
placing her on the opposite side of
umbaku
he starts out as an antagonist
challenging t'challa for the throne but
later saves his life and offers refuge
to his mother
he even ends up helping them fight
killmonger and later thanos
now there's no telling what waits for
these characters in black panther 2.
so what do you think
kind of sweet huh back in 1994 ant-may
and iron man starred in the rom-com only
you
faith played by marissa tomei believes
she has found the man she was destined
to fall in love with
damon bradley played by robert downey jr
she flies to venice to track him down
just days before her wedding to another
man and the two
fall for each other right away but
there's a catch it turns out his name
isn't actually damon bradley while tony
stark did a little bit of flirting with
aunt may in civil
war he was probably just trying to charm
her so she would let peter go to germany
may actually ends up romantically
involved with tony stark's assistant
happy
played by john favreau
hello what is it you look tired we have
another magical match
this time between loki and the ancient
one tom hiddleston and tilda swinton
played lovers in 2013's
only lovers left alive the movie is a
comedic drama about vampires in a
relationship that has endured for
centuries
the two are polar opposites adam being
world weary and depressed
and eve managing to have an upbeat
optimistic look on life
while the two haven't shared any scream
time in the marvel movies
loki's time hopping and dr strange's
multiverse adventures could make
anything possible
even if both characters are technically
dead comic book movies are just as wild
as their source material after all
here's a quick bonus entry for you
elizabeth olsen
and josh brolin scarlet witch and thanos
were love interests in spike lee's
remake of the korean cult classic
old boy we aren't going any deeper into
that one for reasons that are obvious if
you've seen
either version of the film